for people don't know we have a
tradition of giving max bottles of cheap
whiskey at this conference
um this is not a cheap whiskey actually
this is actually nicer than we would
normally give him
so but that comes from one of his his
question is fun facts from the early
conferences
so and he's actually probably has too
much whiskey for me but you know
we're going to keep giving to you until
we just fill your whole house
thank you very much max for being here
yeah right the one virtual conference is
when they choose to give out the good
alcohol to me
so thanks for that uh so i'm going to
talk about
maybe on surprising nobody uh resampling
a little bit but a little
different uh spin on it looking at more
not machine learning models and more
inferential models
specifically related to like repeated
measures
uh the slides are here there's a link at
the very end if you want to um
get them
so i'll mostly be thinking about
multi-level models so multi-level models
like a catch-all
for things like hierarchical linear
models like hierarchical bayesian models
mixed effects random effects random
coefficient models split plots it's like
a
whole host of models sort of fall into
this sort of category
the important things about them and why
people typically use them
is uh we very often have like what i
would call
a independent experimental unit in a
data set
and in most data sets every row is like
the experimental unit that's independent
of the other rows
but you might have other data where for
example
in the example i'll use
we collect data over time on a person so
whereas people are independent
the rows within people are dependent
because they're coming from the same
person
and typically multi-level models are
used for those particular situations to
account for
subject to subject variation or
correlation within subject
and another reason they use them and
this is important for the talk
is that a lot of times if you have an
experiment and you're going to make some
inferences about
let's say a group of subjects or group
of something
if you don't use like a multi-level
model most of your inferences
are confined to the uh specific let's
say subjects that were in your data set
and so the nice thing about like random
effects models and invasion models is
your inferences can be then if you use
those
uh generalized to a broader set like the
population of those experimental units
and so that's one reason that people
typically use them
so in my analysis here i'm going to
focus on this linear mix models um i
feel that they're inferior to bayesian
hierarchical models
but they're a lot faster so i'm going to
be doing some resampling
um i've tested what i'm going to talk
about
um also with like our stain arm and some
other bayesian methods
and i've also tested it across like
three different data sets i'm getting
sort of the same
result so um so what i'll show you here
has been repeatable for me across models
and data sets
so let me show you an example from my
last job when i was in drug discovery
uh we had a lot of laboratory data i
mean we had like like a crazy amount of
laboratory data over decades
and one of the important things we would
do in early drug discovery is try to get
a
like a just a idea of what human
clearance might be
so human clearance is when you ingest a
drug or your injector or whatever
clearance is basically the rate that it
leaves your body
so whether you metabolize it or you
excrete it
or via urine or something like that it's
like how fast is a drug getting out of
your body
and that's a really it's like probably
one of the most critical things you
could measure
um in a drug and so we had a bunch of
laboratory tests where we would
um with a specific type of cells put a
fixed concentration of drug in them
and then monitor them over time to
figure out um how fast they eliminate
so we had like these very large number
of
like repeated measures designs like
longitudinal data
on a so there the experimental unit
would be a drug or what we would call a
compound
and so the most important uh so this is
simulated data here on the left
this data looks remarkably like close to
the kind of data that we were analyzing
at the time it was somewhat
noisy but linear um the most important
things
that we would get from a model and an
analysis like this would be
for an individual compound it would be
the slope because the slope is very
it was like i think it's like one
divided by the half-life or the
half-life is one divided by the slope i
think
um so on a compounded compound basis we
were really interested in knowing what
the
slopes were from these experiments but
if we build a model or did some analysis
we'd have to report
to the users of the analysis and their
management
what the error rate was for the model so
if this is like a linear regression or a
complicated linear regression
we'd have to report like the root mean
squared error and when we needed
something that was like an overall
way to um characterize how well the
model was doing
so that they could when they use it you
know feel confident was doing what they
thought
should be doing and so the focus of this
talk is really going to be about
estimating the error rates of models
especially models that have
[Music]
mixed or multiple levels
so i am going to adhere to what seems
like the new conference norm
of uh doing a single
visualization per slide
so uh we have the teddy models
infrastructure so that includes like
recipes and parsnips and things like
that
we also have like an add-on package that
we haven't released yet it's on github
and what multi-level mod does is it
extends uh our parsnip package
to using like um uh lme4
package for doing modeling we already
used like our stain arm but we would
enable our stand arm to work across
hierarchies like multiple levels and
things like that so when you load this
package it adds some more engines to the
parsnip package the data set that i'll
use
uh it's actually quite an old data set
and it's actually i think the first time
i saw was in like sas documentation
uh but it's a clinical trial uh there's
66 subjects
their outcome is a depression score so
this is like a standardized score that
people use to measure depression
um and then the data is collected every
week
so there's four weeks it's zero based
like zero one two three
and then uh there's a uh indicator for
uh sex
there's another another indicator for
the presence of this endogenous i think
was a protein
and then we have two columns that are
time dependent covariance
so these are covariates uh that change
every time point
and so these will be a little bit
important as the analysis goes on
and so what we'd like to do is we'd like
to model the depression score as a
function of weak
and all these other factors so how would
we do that for example in a multiple
multiple level model
so one of the most common things we can
do is just build like a linear
regression model
but with the exception of uh these first
two terms here
so what this would do is it's what we
call a random intercept model
where we have a overall global
population
intercept for the depression score and
then the i here is over subject
so each subject will get its own
specific intercept in the model
so that we have some specificity per
subject and then we do the same thing
with the slope
so the slope has a global population
slope
and then each individual subject has
their own contribution to that slope
so it's a random slope and intercept
model now we have other
parameters that are more typical where
we don't have subject effects like
related to sex and all the other columns
in the data set including the
metabolites that were in there so when
we go to fit this
i'm going to use lme 4 packets and the
limiter function
and so when you load that extra parsnip
package you can set the engine to be
limmer we also have an engine for stand
glimmer which uses r stain arm
and so that's something else you could
do now we're working the interface
for how to specify the model formula
and this is going to look a little bit
kludgy and here's a link to a better
slightly better interface that we think
will make this easier to use
if you want to take a look at it but
what you do in tiny models is you would
create what we call a model workflow
and a model workflow consists of a model
like a
model object and then some type of
preprocessor and that preprocessor could
be
you know a formula or a recipe or
something like that
and so the confusing part here is we're
going to have two formulas
so the the thing about the model formula
in r is it's really like overloaded with
things that it does
for models like um like a generalized
additive model
or a mixed effects model like we're
going to use
the uh the model formula not only tells
you know the the common r infrastructure
like moderate matrix
like what um columns should be in the
data and how to encode them
in this particular case it encodes also
statistical information
so this formula that i have above here
that has the random intercept
and slope model is really specified by a
model formula we would give the limber
and that says you know we have weak as
an effect
and this little bit of it says the weak
should be
a random effect with random intercepts
and slopes and then we have ordinary
sort of uh coefficients for these other
models
so what you would do is your formula
here would basically have the outcome
tilde and dot and what what tidy models
would know to do for this particular
type of model
is not take a subject for example and
make dummy variables out of it
because then that would be not really
usable by the limber function
so this formula here is really more
about like data preprocessing
and then when you add the model to the
workflow you can add an additional model
formula
and this model formula gets passed
directly to limer or
or stain arm or whatever package or
function
you're using within the analysis package
so it's like two levels of formulas
and again we think we'll have a better
way of doing that in this pr
but once that's specified then it's
really simple and just use the fit
function
you give it the data set and you get
your model back
so let's look at that real quick that's
my dog snoring behind me if you can hear
that
sorry
when you print the fitted model it's
basically what you would get if you
would use the model directly
the things i'll point out in the model
output here is the residual
so this 3.25 is the estimate of the root
mean squared error of this particular
model
um it's used by basically reproducting
the training set and calculating
what the arma c is generally we don't
think that's a great idea and we'll talk
about that a little bit more
it tells you for example there are
random effects due to the intercept
and the slope and then it cause them
fixed effects but they're really like
the population
parameters for this model so across all
the subjects the average
slope for the population would be about
about negative two
um the intercept on average is about 1.3
and so that's the output that we would
get so this is pretty straightforward
the only you know change here is how we
would fit this using tiny models
so you know i said we'd have like you
know one plot per page and i'm sticking
to that but it's
it's you know it's like a wall of data
here
um so when we look at the model fit um
by repredicting the data set uh with all
the subjects
we see for the most part most of these
lines are pretty close to the original
like observed data there's some case
where they bend a little bit and this
would be a situation where for example
those time dependent covariates for the
metabolites
having a big effect on the model you see
there are some subjects like three or
five here
that has you know a pretty a pretty uh
negative slope
we do have some like 113 or
360 that are bordering on you know low
positive slopes so we do see some
variation in the slopes here
so you know oh no i think we'd look at
this model and say yeah that's coming
pretty
close to the data and might feel that
it's sufficient
um but here's the question that i want
to know is
and this is more motivated by the types
of problems that used to work on is
well how would this model fit for a new
subject
so you know we know at least for machine
learning that
uh if we take the same data that was
used to fit our model
and repredict it and measure model
performance from it
you know on average those models tend to
be or those model performance estimates
tend to be
optimistic so just re-predicting the
training set even though we can get like
a root mean squared error
it might not be a very good estimate of
root mean squared error because
there's a lot of things baked into the
data that might not reflect what would
happen on new subjects
so what i'll spend the rest of the time
doing is talking about what would happen
with new subjects
so you know as i mentioned previously um
i'd really be focused on what the error
estimate is like the root mean squared
error
and some people might be saying well
like well don't we don't really use that
we use like
uh information criteria statistics like
aic or bic
but i'm not really worried about model
comparisons here i'm really worried
about
you know having to communicate to the
end user of a model like this what the
error rate is and it's in the units that
they know about
so they tend to be able to interpret it
pretty well in this particular case i
don't think aic or bic is really what
they'd be interested in
even though it's you know it's a
penalized version based on number of
parameters
relative the number of data points so
the likelihood i think they really would
much rather have a
an rmse so our sort of in model estimate
or uh is 3.25 and so the question is
what would happen if we had a new sample
like a new subject
so what we would do is use for example
one thing we could do is to leave one
out we
leave one subject out cross validation
and so
we have 66 subjects so we would fit
66 different models the first model
takes out you know the first subject and
fits the model on the remaining 65
and then predicts that one held out
subjects data and computes the arma c
from that
and then you would just go round robin
through all the subjects
and get 66 estimates of rmse
that are relative to each subject and so
typically with resampling what we do is
we take the average of our
resampling estimates and use that as our
generalization error
so if we take the average of those 66 uh
rmc values that should be indicative of
what we would see
for new samples for new subjects
and it turns out in tiny models that's
really easy we have a
control object we'll set that we'll save
the prediction so we can show some more
plots we already have a function that
can do leave
subject out we would give it give this
group v
fold cv function the data set
and then the column that corresponds to
the um
the uh experimental unit which is
subject here
and then our fit resamples function is
already designed to do resampling
doesn't do any model tuning or anything
it just like re-samples the same model
across different um objects that are
created by the r sample
package so the result of this is a table
that has all the
you know leave one out information in it
as you'll see in a minute there's a
function called collect metrics
and collect metrics we'll then add to
the averaging of the 66 and show you
what the
overall armaci is and so when we look at
that again remember our benchmark for
the in sample
pharmacy is 3.25 and then when we do
that
surprise pikachu um we get that and it's
the leave subject out estimate is almost
twice as high
so in you know instead of three and so
here on this
um visualization is the in sample
estimate
here's the estimate when we leave them
out and then the rug plot here
shows what the individual arm and z's
are and you can see some of them
are like five-fold larger than the
original
so uh or the original in sample so you
know i was quite taken aback by this and
thought
wow i'm really surprised that it's that
bad um
very often when you take like a pretty
simple
high bias model or variance model like
linear regression
and resample it usually uh the
resample performance estimates or at
least within the ballpark
of the one that uses reproduction
um that's not true of many other models
but usually true linear regression
and so i was very kind of surprised by
this and and so the rest of talk is
like um sort of the summary of how i
figured out that i didn't make a mistake
i believe so let's talk about you know
how this happened why
why is performance so bad when we leave
the subject out
and so to talk about that we should talk
about how we do actual estimation
both in the model and how the model is
being used for prediction when you're
using a multi-level model
so you know as we said before each
subject has their own specific
uh slope and intercept and so when we
have that slope and intercept
what we do or the way the model works is
it basically
um uh does something called shrinkage or
partial pooling depending on what sort
of school you're coming from
and what it does is if you were to take
the individual slope and intercept
estimates by just fitting a bunch of
separate models for each subject
what the partial pooling and trinkage
does is it sort of shrinks them down
towards the average
so it's shrinking them towards like the
population estimate
of the slope and the intercept and
that's sort of visualized
so for example like this one subject
here had a relatively
negative intercept and that's when you
just fit it using
just that subject's data but in the
multi-level model that had shrunken way
way closer
to the population average of intercepts
and you see the same thing happens with
slopes
and so you know we're already shrinking
them towards and this is basically
regularization
we're shrinking them so that we get
generally better parameter
estimates at least having statistical
properties that are better
so that's what happens inside the model
the main reason i bring this
up is because in order to do this within
the model
you need the actual slopes and
intercepts and you can't compute the
slope's intercepts
unless you have the actual hold out data
like the outcome data
so in this case we can't do this for the
depression for data where we don't have
the depression scores
so in sample we have everything we need
to do the shrinkage on a
subject-by-subject basis
but think about when we predict a new
sample we want to know what their
outcome data are we don't necessarily
have it
and so how does the how do these types
of models
deal with the situation where they're
making predictions on a subject
where we don't know what their outcome
is
so looking at these populations of slope
and intercepts what we typically do
when we fit these models is we realize
they're coming from a population
and we you know we already pre-specified
a distribution that we think that they
come from
so when we have a new data point what we
typically do is
depending on how the models fit we get
the distribution
of these parameters and basically use
the the population value which is some
estimate of the middle of the subject
specific effects
so if you're fitting like linear or a
linear mixed model
this would be the average basically of
the coefficients
if you're doing a bayesian model would
be the mode of the distribution
and so on so what happens is in sample
we're making a prediction about a
subject that was used in the model fit
they have their own subject specific
slopes and intercepts because that's how
the model works
but we have a new subject coming in they
don't have subject
specific uh coefficients available to
them and so they use the overall
population estimate
to make the predictions so they still
have all these other covariates that are
used the same as they would have been
but the actual random effects are not
random effects anymore because we don't
have data
to compute the subject specific parts so
basically what this means is
across week all of our new samples are
starting off with the exact same slope
and intercept rather
whether that's appropriate or not so now
let's look at those model fits
when we held out the data
so when these curves a dotted line or
the original in sample predictions
and the saw lines are the predictions
that are coming when this particular
subject was held out and so you can see
for subject 101 here
you know the intercept is maybe not off
by that much but definitely the slope is
is you know not so hot there's some
like down here 360 where
you know we thought that previously we
had a you know maybe
zero or slightly positive slope here but
we're constrained by the
the way we do prediction to have a
negative slope so you know if we're
looking for the subjects that had a
five-fold higher rmse compared to the
in-sample prediction this is exactly
what's going on
so we have a number of subjects here
whose
predicted value is nowhere near the
observed data points
whereas many of them are so for example
if we take subject 350 over here
we can see that those bits are right on
top of each other and that's because its
original
slope and intercept from the mixed level
model was
very much in the middle of that
population
so you know this wasn't like a bug in
code this is a real thing
um about and it's much very much related
to how we make predictions for these
types of models
and it does make me think of it being
basically a product of what we call
information leakage
so information leakage is the idea that
um
the idea that um when you're making a
prediction on a new sample
you shouldn't be dipping into the raw
data of the original data set
to make predictions and so it's it
basically leads to a type of bias
that could artificially make your
predictions look better than they
actually are
so we tend to want to make predictions
on new data and keep those very
very much confined and quarantined we
don't want to
have the original training set enter
into it and so when we make predictions
uh in sample predictions from these
types of models they're very much have
information leakage because they're
using the outcome of the data
to then predict the outcome data you
don't have that with new data points and
it's a little bit problematic because if
you think about why we use these types
of models
we use them because they generalize well
like in an inference
so when we when we make inferences about
you know the effect of weak
over time on depression we want to make
that inference to the larger
population of subjects we don't want to
say well for these 66 subjects here's
what happened
and so if our generalization error for
these types of models is very large
compared to their in-simple error
it does make you wonder about the the
quality of our entrance
um in terms of um generalization
uh when one caveat to this and i
mentioned i tried this on a bunch of
different data sets and saw the same
patterns
but if you did have strong time very
time varying covariates
for example like the metabolites that i
mentioned
then this wouldn't really happen so much
because you'd be diminishing the effect
of let's say slope and intercept you
would have other terms in the model that
would dominate
and your predictions would be better
whether it's in sample or out of the
sample
so this isn't like guaranteed to happen
for every
linear mixed model or hierarchical model
it depends on the coverage and how
they're entered in the model
but anyway it was an interesting uh
phenomenon that i
observed and i thought i'd share with
everybody so thanks and uh
slides are right here if you want them
thank you max and uh that concludes dr
hour
before we head to our break